i don't know it's just a feeling it's
like everything like how you go bad
outfit
it's a feeling you might just want
something you know something to see
something
walk into the jury store get your stuff
clean and walk out with something new
i also was escg i'm here with gq
and you're watching on the rocks this
probably was my first like
ten thousand dollar piece this design
was like my first
like diamond pendant probably like two
years now i had another g
pendant before this it was kind of like
this but the bell was different instead
of the esc
right here the esc was on the bail g's
with g
and the esc's for everybody trying to
get them you got a comment with
everybody else call me
g
it's a kilo cuban it's 65 000.
this is from ivy in new york and i got a
half kilo cuban from waffy and they were
charging like 50 for like to have kilo q
and he showed me love let me get it for
35 big time it's kind of different when
he is
a honeycomb maybe where they real tight
together and down in there
and then this one it's like prongs said
like
damages on the inside of a prong when
they bigger i think they look good
together
i got this from jury unlimited 2 from
waffy
he got this like custom bills like you
don't gotta slide it all the way off
your chain
you can like clip and they got the logo
for efc it's like a key
and they got my brother on the back this
was 35 we got two of them done at the
same time a yellow one and a white one
so you know he gave us a little deal
the cmg piece right here and then it's
got baguettes on the front of it
classic logo it's another special piece
with the
wifey clamp he liked the first jewel
i've seen to do this [ __ ] like
yeah chain right here i got this from
yv2
15 20 something like that this is
another little baguette it's like a
smaller version of that one kind of
i always see with these like little
mini est pieces i'm saying all of us got
one of these
white gold yellow gold paid for these
and my watching all at the same time as
well
i was really caught up on some of the
prices because i gave them a lot of
money at once
they 3 500 a piece i got 20 of them
favorite piece this is my mama right
here i got this for my birthday
julian unlimited wifey did this so
20 point attendance chain you know
everybody else's fidget spinner most
just be like a gold background a white
girl background i got diamonds on
these bust down penis like that they're
probably anywhere from
12 to 15. and you know wifey ain't
really giving no deal so
he gonna make sure you get his money
my teeth look at johnny dane he's his
permanent honeycomb set i was eating
chick-fil-a he actually some chicken mrt
don't worry about that when i pay 24
000.
[Music]
i know it's like clustering right here
this one's cheapest like 4500 then i got
these two baguette ones
from ivy in new york i think i paid
like 12 for one five for the other ones
and i got this huge impression from
iceman nick too
and ap i am rose ap it's
new what i'm saying with the clocks on
the bottom one a lot of people got the
ap with the clock at the 12
nine and the six that's the older one
and it'd be looking kind of fat with
big rubber bands so this is the new one
with the jumbo bezel and it's gonna run
you anywhere from 6 to 65. i got this
from iceman nick he charged me 63.
dweller and this is a custom one right
here from wifey
got the big diamonds on the side then
it's like all different size diamonds
this is like the first
batch of these that he made too i think
he's like the patent for this like the
different size damage in the band
there's a titanium ap right here it's
like for some low-key
kicking this is a jumbo cardio
xl santos my man nigel gave this to me
um those aren't like the other cardio
so yeah master got this from ice man
nick it's right here 75 just 40. this is
gear and this is 40. i'm saying with esc
man
i can help you out
i got this for my birthday too est i got
the same logo as on the
little change so let me say 55 on the
side
street number and then they got my name
at the bottom well i think this is like
1205 and it's a good diamond
it's an old style ring everybody had a
starter and i feel like this business oh
it's kind of cheap too it's like three
grand i think i got this in atlanta it's
static
pieces oh yeah
i ain't seen nobody with no animals on
the side of this [ __ ]
so when y'all see you it's just no it's
just you did this
spend a hundred or something with [ __ ]
go get you something like that
all right man thank y'all for coming to
check out my jury on the rocks
i'm saying with gq actually i go uh
string my newest single
capital one and be on the lookout for
bigger than life for death see i pay
attention to this [ __ ] man don't take
the cheap boy